Scientists have long wondered
why humans like music and why we're so good
at making it.
Our love affair has deep roots
even our closest primate cousins
have been seen banging out riffs in the wild
but what makes music... MUSIC?
Scientists have identified 18 so-called
music universals.
Six of them are related to rhythm.
They include:
The universals came from 304 recordings of
music around the world
But do they hold up
when people invent music from scratch?
To find out scientists asked
non-musicians to play a game of telephone.
The first person tried to imitate random
drumming noise from a computer.
The second person tried to imitate the first.
By the time the final person laid down
their riffs something amazing happened.
The random beats had transformed into
easy-to-learn highly structured patterns
that reflected all six universals.
This, says scientists, might not explain
why we like music.
It might help explain
how our brains are wired to produce it.